From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday,
祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，
Mr. Presumptive Republican Nominee,
共和党推定提名人先生，
Happy birthday to you.
祝你生日快乐。
Everybody, happy birthday.
各位，生日快乐。
See, this is the kind of event the Bob Dole campaign should have staged when he turned 73 this past week. They should have surrounded him with lively, young people, a big, happy event celebrating his vigor. A few of you may not know that particular piece of tape. It's a pretty famous piece of tape. It's Marilyn Monroe singing to John Kennedy in 1963, which in my view, makes it even more appropriate for Bob Dole to use.
你看，这就是鲍勃·多尔竞选团队在上周他73岁生日时本应策划的活动。他们本应该让他被活泼的年轻人包围，举办一场庆祝他活力的盛大而快乐的活动。你们中可能有些人不知道那段录像。那是一段非常有名的录像。1963年玛丽莲·梦露为约翰·肯尼迪演唱，在我看来，这让鲍勃·多尔使用它显得更加合适。
Marilyn Monroe and John Kennedy are his contemporaries, after all. Bob Dole is 73. If Marilyn Monroe were alive, she would be 70. John Kennedy would be 79.
毕竟，玛丽莲·梦露和约翰·肯尼迪是他的同代人。鲍勃·多尔今年73岁。如果玛丽莲·梦露还活着，她今年70岁。约翰·肯尼迪应该是79岁。
But instead of a big, lively event, a hall full of boisterous young people, where did the Dole for President campaign stage its big birthday photo op? In an old age home. There in the paper, you could see the pictures, Bob Dole with some senior citizens.
但多尔的总统竞选团队没有举办一场盛大而活泼的活动、没有满厅喧闹的年轻人，而是把他的大型生日拍照活动安排在哪里呢？在养老院。报纸上的照片里，鲍勃·多尔和一些老年人在一起。
You really had to wonder, what were they thinking? What message are they trying to get across to us? Does this campaign have the will to live?
你真的不得不怀疑，他们是怎么想的？他们试图向我们传达什么信息？这个竞选团队还有活下去的意志吗？
Well, each week here on This American Life, we choose a theme, invite a wide variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme with documentaries, radio monologues, reportage, found tape, occasional radio dramas, basically, anything they can think of. And today, we bring you perspectives on Bob Dole. Because at this point, there's something oddly mesmerizing about what's going on in that campaign. Barely a day goes by without some odd quote or strange gaffe.
每周在《美国生活》节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过纪录片、广播独白、报道、发现的录音、偶尔的广播剧，基本上是任何他们能想到的方式，来探讨这个主题。今天，我们为您带来关于鲍勃·多尔的各种视角。因为在这一点上，这场竞选运动中发生的事情有一种奇特的吸引力。几乎每一天都会出现一些奇怪的引语或尴尬的失言。
Just at the end of this past week, there was a thing in the news how the Republicans have booked themself into a convention hall for the Republican Convention. And it's like 14 feet tall. And TV Guide was quoted in there saying that he doesn't want to make them look bad or anything, but there is literally no way to film them, to shoot them for TV, which is the entire point of a modern political convention. There's no way to shoot them without them looking like ants on a postage stamp.
就在过去这一周结束时，新闻里提到共和党人把自己预定在一个大厅里举行共和党全国代表大会。而那个厅只有14英尺高。《电视指南》援引话说，他并不想让他们看起来不好看，但实际上根本没法拍摄他们，没法为电视节目拍摄，而这正是现代政治大会的核心所在。不让他们看起来像邮票上的蚂蚁，根本没法拍摄。
And I see this stuff. And really, my heart just goes out to the man. Something deep and codependent in me wants to step in and help him out.
我看到这些东西。真的，我的心真的很同情这个人。我内心深处有一种依赖性的东西想要介入并帮助他。
Anyway, our program today in three acts. Act One, Campaign Diaries.
无论如何，我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，竞选日记。
Act Two, Instructions on How You Can Become Bob Dole.
第二幕，关于如何成为鲍勃·多尔的说明。
Act Three, a writer who we've been trying to get on our program for a while, actually, a guy named Danny Drennan. Usually, he writes about things like the TV show Beverly Hills , 90210. And we gave him a little assignment. Anyway, stay with us.
第三幕，一位我们试图邀请到节目中已有一段时间的作家，其实是一个叫丹尼·德雷南的人。通常他写关于电视剧《飞越比弗利》之类的内容。我们给了他一个小任务。无论如何，请继续收听。
Act One, Campaign Diaries. Well, before on this program, once before, we've featured the campaign diaries of Michael Lewis. And he is covering the political campaigns. He's one of the people writing for The New Republic.
第一幕，竞选日记。在这一节目之前，我们曾有一次播放过迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记。他正在报道政治竞选。他是为《新共和》撰稿的作家之一。
And his writing is really some of the most remarkable writing anybody is doing about the campaigns, because basically, he's this really funny, smart guy who writes like a novelist, more than like a political reporter, though there's a lot of political analysis in it. The political analysis gets encased in these scenes, in these little stories. And it's just a complete pleasure to read. And then he's just got a really great eye, a really great eye for the telling moment. And he's been following around all the different candidates.
他的写作确实是关于竞选的报道中最引人注目的，因为他基本上是一个非常有趣、聪明的家伙，写起东西来更像小说家，而不是政治记者，尽管其中有很多政治分析。政治分析被包裹在这些场景中，在这些小故事中。阅读起来简直是一种纯粹的享受。而且他有一双非常敏锐的眼睛，能发现那些意味深长的时刻。他一直追随着所有不同的候选人。
We're going to play you now a set of stuff that he's written about Dole, just because, among other things, he captures all these moments nobody else gets. And they reveal all these things about Dole and his campaign. I'm going to start with this. Let me get some music going here again.
我们现在要为您播放一系列他关于多尔的报道，因为除其他原因外，他捕捉到了所有其他人没有发现的时刻。它们揭示了关于多尔和他的竞选活动的所有这些事情。我要从这里开始。让我再放点音乐。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
There we go. This first little diary entry is from back during the primaries. This is February 15. This is after the final New Hampshire debate. And this is this debate where there was this one moment where Dole kind of got into a little shouting match with Steve Forbes. Remember him?
好了。这第一篇日记条目是在初选期间的。这是2月15日。这是在新罕布什尔州最后一场辩论之后。在那场辩论中，有那么一刻，多尔和史蒂夫·福布斯发生了一点争吵。还记得他吗？
And Dole basically said to Forbes-- Forbes was running all these negative ads. And Dole's staff or Dole came up with this stunt where Dole would say "Those ads are really inaccurate. And plus, if you're going to be talking about me, you could at least use a decent picture." And then Dole hands him these pictures, which Forbes snaps back at him, this and that.
多尔基本上对福布斯说——福布斯一直在发布所有这些负面广告。多尔的员工或多尔想出了一个噱头，多尔会说：“那些广告非常不准确。而且，如果你要谈论我，你至少可以用一张像样的照片。”然后多尔把这些照片递给他，福布斯又回敬他，诸如此类。
OK. So all that gets covered in the press. But after the debate, people leave. The stage is empty. And our little Michael Lewis heads out onto the stage. And he's looking at all the detritus left over, the notes the candidates write themselves, all this stuff that nobody else really bothers with writing about.
好吧。所有这些都在媒体报道中。但在辩论之后，人们离开了。舞台空了。我们的小迈克尔·刘易斯走向舞台。他在查看留下的所有残余物，候选人自己写的笔记，所有其他人根本懒得写的东西。
And then he sees the photographs. I'm going to read from this campaign diary, and then we'll go to Michael reading. He says, "I noticed the photographs. They lay on the shelf beneath Forbes's podium. They were not prints but originals, curled and soiled, as if they'd been sitting in some shoebox for years, until Dole stumbled across them late one night while he was worrying about how to retaliate against Steve Forbes in the big debate.
然后他看到了照片。我要读一下这篇竞选日记，然后我们转到迈克尔的朗读。他说：“我注意到了那些照片。它们放在福布斯讲台下方的架子上。它们不是打印件，而是原件，卷曲且污损，就好像它们已经在某个鞋盒里放了很多年，直到多尔在一个深夜里绞尽脑汁想在大辩论中如何报复史蒂夫·福布斯时无意中发现了它们。”
Two are color, a bad one of Liddy, Dole's wife, who's stunning in the flesh, looking here tired and plain. A better one of dole's dog, Leader, rubbing noses with a yellow lab. The third is a black and white, of Dole smiling broadly, holding a baby. He looks 20 years younger. The black pen he clutches to keep his right arm in place juts up and is set off by the baby's white gown. Dole is looking at the camera. The baby is looking at Dole's gnarled, wounded hand." Here's Michael Lewis.
两张是彩色的，一张多尔的妻子莉迪的照片拍得很糟糕，她本人风采绝佳，但照片里看起来很疲惫且相貌平平。另一张是多尔的狗“领袖”和一只黄色拉布拉多犬碰鼻子的照片，拍得更好些。第三张是黑白的，多尔笑得很灿烂，抱着一个婴儿。他看起来年轻了20岁。他为固定右臂而紧握的黑钢笔翘了起来，并被婴儿的白色长袍衬托出来。多尔正看着镜头。婴儿正看着多尔那双弯曲、受伤的手。”这是迈克尔·刘易斯。
I asked five different Dole aides the identity of the baby held by Dole in the photograph he gave to Forbes. It seems an innocent enough query. After all, this was the picture Dole had selected for publication. I get no answer.
我问了五位不同的多尔助手，多尔在那张给福布斯的照片里抱着的婴儿是谁。这似乎是一个足够无辜的查询。毕竟，这是多尔选择发布的那张照片。我没有得到答案。
The basic pose of the Dole campaign is the less anyone finds out about their candidate, the better. You can spot the Dole office in the row of glass boxes on the ground floor of the New Hampshire Holiday Inn. It's the one with the newspaper taped up on the glass to prevent people from outside looking in. Dole himself remains largely out of sight. He makes two or three very brief appearances each day and is otherwise unavailable for interviews.
多尔竞选团队的基本姿态是，关于他们的候选人，别人发现的越少越好。你可以在新罕布什尔假日酒店底层的玻璃盒子那一排中找到多尔的办公室。那个贴着报纸以防止外面的人窥视的办公室就是。多尔本人基本隐身。他每天只露面两三次，除此之外不接受采访。
Dole's speeches add nothing to the general blank picture. A dozen times I listened to his talk, pen poised idly over paper. Nothing, not a thought, not an image, not a quote.
多尔的演讲对整体空白的画面毫无增益。我听过十几次他的演讲，笔闲置在纸上。什么都没有，没有思想，没有图像，没有引语。
It took me a while to figure out why this was, but then it struck me. Bob Dole wasn't running for president. The concept of Bob Dole was running. The man himself had subcontracted out all the dirty work to people who make their careers out of this sort of thing. That was why he was referring to himself in the third person. He wasn't there, at least not in any meaningful way.
我花了一段时间才弄明白这是为什么，但后来我突然意识到。鲍勃·多尔不是在竞选总统。是“鲍勃·多尔”这个概念在竞选。他本人已经把所有的脏活累活外包给了那些以此为职业的人。这就是他以第三人称指代自己的原因。他不在那里，至少在任何有意义的层面上都不在。
It turns out that everything I will discover about Bob Dole, I will discover by stealth. My first discovery? He's embarrassed by his own vanity. I catch him in a back room at one event, just before he's about to go onstage. He thinks no one is looking. He checks out his reflection furtively. His hair is sprayed and dyed. And then he whips out of his pocket a tiny canister and squirts two quick blasts of breath spray into his mouth.
结果发现，关于鲍勃·多尔我所发现的一切，都是我通过潜行发现的。我的第一个发现？他为自己的虚荣心感到尴尬。我在一个活动中，在他即将上台前，在后台抓住了他。他以为没有人看见。他偷偷摸摸地查看自己的倒影。他的头发喷了发胶并染过。然后他从口袋里掏出一个小罐子，往嘴里喷了两下口气清新剂。
Also, his wit is genuine. It's not just an act. I stalk him through the snow at the world dog sledding championships and watch him meet and greet the pooches. A schoolgirl approaches as he's about to leave and after nabbing a photo, asks him if he's having fun. "You learn a lot out here campaigning," Dole says, motioning to a sled of 20 dogs. "They're all nice dogs, too, not like the Congress." He thinks no one is listening. He's said it just for the fun of it.
此外，他的机智是真实的。这不仅仅是在演戏。我在世界狗拉雪橇锦标赛的雪地里跟踪他，看着他与狗狗们打招呼。当他准备离开时，一名女学生走过来，拍了一张照片后，问他玩得开心吗。“你在这种竞选活动中学到很多，”多尔说着，示意着一辆20条狗拉的雪橇。“它们也都是好狗，不像国会。”他以为没有人听。他只是随口说说而已。
All other data about Bob Dole must be inferred from the world he has created around himself. The Dole campaign consists of slick young men in blue suits, forever whispering to each other in dark corners. The campaign pays top dollar for everything. And I get the feeling that most who work for it have some personal financial stake in Dole soldiering on, and that they'll be the last to tell him that he really shouldn't be doing this again.
关于鲍勃·多尔的所有其他数据都必须从他围绕自己创造的世界中推断出来。多尔的竞选团队由穿着蓝色西装、在黑暗角落里窃窃私语的时髦年轻人组成。竞选活动在一切事情上都花大钱。我有一种感觉，大多数为他工作的人在多尔坚持到底这件事上有个人经济利益，他们将是最后告诉他他不应该再这样做的人。
You also get the feeling that there is very little the campaign would not do. One of their favorite techniques has been to hire telemarketing firms to call Buchanan supporters and, in the guise of pollsters, relate damning untruths. In response to Buchanan's complaints, the Dole people tell reporters that Buchanan is doing the calling to a few of his supporters to tar Dole. It takes a special sort of credulity to believe them. I stopped half a dozen people carrying Buchanan signs who told the same stories of strange phone calls in the night.
你还会有一种感觉，这个竞选团队没有什么做不出来的。他们最喜欢的技术之一是雇佣电话营销公司给布坎南的支持者打电话，以民调员的幌子，散布破坏性的谎言。为了回应布坎南的抱怨，多尔的人告诉记者，是布坎南在给自己的几个支持者打电话，试图抹黑多尔。相信他们需要一种特殊的轻信。我拦住了半打带着布坎南标志的人，他们都说了同样关于夜晚接到奇怪电话的故事。
One afternoon, I abandoned the Dole campaign for the steam room at the Manchester YMCA to purge myself of the dreadful feeling coming over me. A few minutes later, an extremely fat old man waddles in, spies me, drops his towel, and sits on a plastic stool right next to me. "You're a new face," he says. "I always notice a new face." I say, "That's nice," grab for a towel, and tell him I came for the campaign.
一天下午，我放弃了多尔的竞选活动，去了曼彻斯特基督教青年会的蒸汽浴室，为了清除我心中那种可怕的感觉。几分钟后，一个极其肥胖的老人摇摇晃晃地走进来，发现了我，脱掉毛巾，坐在我旁边的一张塑料凳上。“你是一张新面孔，”他说。“我总是能注意到新面孔。”我说，“那挺好，”抓过毛巾，告诉他我是为了竞选活动而来的。
He shifts on his stool and says, "I'm a Buchanan man, myself." Buchanan men are the kind of guys who can sidle up to other guys in steam rooms without the slightest fear of being thought gay. Moments later, he's complaining about the calls he's getting at home. Here, roughly, is what he said.
他在凳子上挪了挪说：“我自己是个布坎南支持者。”布坎南支持者就是那种可以在蒸汽浴室里凑到其他人身边而不必担心被认为同性恋的那种人。片刻之后，他开始抱怨他在家接到的电话。这就是他所说的大致内容。
"A guy calls. He says, 'Hi. My name is William, and I'm calling from the Dole campaign. Are you aware that Pat Buchanan is an extremist?' And I say, 'What do you mean?' And he says, 'Pat wants to give nuclear weapons to South Korea and Japan.'
“有人打电话。他说，‘你好。我叫威廉，我从多尔竞选团队打来电话。你知道帕特·布坎南是个极端分子吗？’我说，‘你是什么意思？’他说，‘帕特想把核武器给韩国和日本。’”
So I ask him, 'Where does this information come from.' He says he doesn't know. So I ask him, 'What does Bob Dole think about that?' And this kid doesn't know that, either. He knows absolutely nothing about Bob Dole.
所以我问他，“这些信息是从哪来的。”他说他不知道。所以我问他，“鲍勃·多尔对此怎么看？”这孩子也不知道。他对比鲍勃·多尔一无所知。
So I ask, 'Who are you, anyway?' And he says he's with an organization called the National Research Institute in Houston. So I ask him for his phone number. And he says he can't give it to me. Then he hangs up. There is, of course, no listing in Houston for the National Research Institute."
所以我问，“你到底是哪位？”他说他是休斯顿一家叫国家研究所的机构的。所以我问他的电话号码。他说他不能给我。然后他就挂断了。当然，休斯顿根本没有国家研究所的电话登记。
In short, the Dole campaign is a lot like what a lot of people probably suspect the Buchanan campaign is, closed, secretive, smug, a bit nasty. Maybe that's what happens when you lose once too often. You stop trusting the voters.
简而言之，多尔的竞选团队很像许多人可能怀疑的布坎南竞选团队，封闭、秘密、自以为是、有点卑鄙。也许这就是当你输得太频繁时会发生的事情。你不再信任选民了。
And yet I still want badly to like Dole. I'll bet he's the guy in the race that people most badly want to like, but can't quite figure out how to do it. Every night after a day with Dole, I return home and recall to my mind a pair of mental images that the day has badly blemished. The first is the one of Dole recuperating from his war wounds, as described by Richard Ben Cramer, hanging by his bad right arm and trying to straighten it out until he was sweating and crying from pain. The second is a windy afternoon last June in a graveyard on the French coast, when, Dole now says, he realized he had to run for president one last time.
然而我还是很想喜欢多尔。我敢打赌，他是竞选中人们最想喜欢，却又搞不懂如何去喜欢的人。每天与多尔相处后，我回到家，脑海中浮现出两幅被这一天严重破坏的心理图像。第一幅是理查德·本·克莱默描述的，多尔在战争创伤中康复，悬挂着他那条残疾的右臂，试图把它拉直，直到他因为痛苦而汗流浃背、泪流满面。第二幅是去年六月的一个多风的下午，在法国海岸的一个墓地，多尔现在说，他意识到他必须最后一次竞选总统。
I traveled there on Clinton's plane to witness the D-Day celebrations. But about halfway through, I lost interest in writing about it and just started watching. You gaze down the cliff onto the beach and just marvel. How did these men do this?
我乘克林顿的飞机去那里见证诺曼底登陆纪念活动。但中途，我对写它失去了兴趣，只是开始观察。你凝视着悬崖下的海滩，感到惊叹。这些人是怎么做到的？
Just before Clinton addressed the veterans of the Normandy invasion, I found myself walking alone through the rows of white crosses, until I reached a place where there was no one else but a pair of veterans. They seemed ancient, though of course, they could not have been much older than Bob Dole. They were trembling and leaning on each other as they looked down on a cross. And at first, I thought it was just from the strains of age.
就在克林顿向诺曼底登陆的退伍军人发表演讲之前，我发现自己独自走在白色的十字架丛中，直到我到达了一个除了两名退伍军人外没有其他人的地方。他们看起来非常古老，当然，他们不可能比鲍勃·多尔大多少。他们颤抖着，互相倚靠着，向下看着一个十字架。起初，我以为这只是岁月造成的。
Then I saw the name and place on the cross, Stenson, I'll say, from Mississippi. The boy had died at the age of 19 on the first day of the invasion. The old men wore name tags, too. Stenson, from Mississippi.
然后我看到了十字架上的名字和地点，史坦森，我就这么称呼他吧，来自密西西比州。这个男孩在入侵的第一天就去世了，年仅19岁。老人们也戴着名字标签。史坦森，来自密西西比州。
Two of three brothers had survived that day. They were crying without tears. That's a bit like Dole, I would like to believe. He's crying without tears. He has the emotions, or at least, you can sense them lurking inside them. But he has no idea how to give them proper expression.
三个兄弟中有两个在那一天幸存下来。他们无声地哭泣。多尔也有点像那样，我愿意相信。他在无声地哭泣。他有感情，或者至少，你能感觉到它们潜伏在他内心深处。但他不知道该如何给它们适当的表达。
Michael Lewis. We'll continue with his campaign diaries in a bit. It's This American Life.
迈克尔·刘易斯。我们稍后将继续他的竞选日记。这里是《美国生活》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "THE DUTCH BOY" BY THE HANDSOME FAMILY]
[音乐播放 - 汉森家族演唱的《荷兰男孩》]
That's The Handsome Family, a Chicago band. We'll have more campaign diaries from Michael Lewis in a second. First, I wanted to read a little bit from this piece written by Andrew Sullivan, also in The New Republic. Figured we're doing one, might as well do the other. It's this lovely little piece of writing from a couple weeks ago.
那是汉森家族，一个芝加哥乐队。我们马上会带来迈克尔·刘易斯的更多竞选日记。首先，我想读一点安德鲁·沙利文写的东西，也刊登在《新共和》上。我想既然我们做了这一个，不妨也做另一个。这是几周前的一篇优美的小文章。
He begins this thing by talking about this sketch that apparently, they're doing on Saturday Night Live. It's a spoof of MTV's show, The Real World. And in the real show, The Real World it's a bunch of young people in their 20s, Generation X-ers, living in a home somewhere. And they locate the home in different places.
他开始写这篇文章时，谈到了他们显然在《周六夜现场》做的那个小品。这是对MTV节目《真实世界》的恶搞。在真正的节目《真实世界》中，是一群20多岁的年轻人，“X世代”的人，住在家里的某个地方。他们把家选在不同的地方。
In the spoof, it's the same setup, except apparently, Bob Dole is living there with them. And then that's the big joke, that this gruff, 70-something person is living with the 20-somethings. And Andrew Sullivan makes the case, no, no, there's actually something to be learned from this. There's actually a deeper truth that we can find in this. He writes the following.
在恶搞版中，设置是一样的，除了显然鲍勃·多尔和他们住在一起。这就是大笑话，这个脾气暴躁的70多岁的人和20多岁的人住在一起。安德鲁·沙利文提出了一个观点，不，不，实际上从中可以学到一些东西。实际上我们可以从中发现更深层的真相。他写道：
"Bob Dole, very unlike his rival for the presidency, is actually, I think, a natural Gen X-er, someone whose ironic detachment, bleak humor, and occasional bursts of dark sentiment make him far more intelligible to the under-35 crowd than most politicians. At 72, he is in some ways the ultimate 20-something candidate. To wit, his remarkable, revealing, and insistent use of that quintessential Generation X mantra, 'whatever.'"
“鲍勃·多尔与他的总统竞选对手非常不同，实际上，我认为他是一个天生的X世代，一个有着讽刺式的超脱、忧郁的幽默，以及偶尔爆发的暗淡情感的人，这使他比大多数政治家更能让35岁以下的人群理解。72岁的他，在某些方面是终极的20多岁的候选人。也就是说，他显著、具有启发性且坚持使用那个典型的X世代咒语，‘无所谓’。”
And then he's got a whole bunch of examples of Bob Dole using the word whatever, whoever, wherever, the various permutations. Here are some. Let's see.
然后他列举了一大堆鲍勃·多尔使用“无所谓”、“无论谁”、“无论哪儿”以及各种变体的例子。这里有一些。让我们看看。
"Well, I think Lowell  Weicker probably did more in the Congress of the United States for disabled people in this country, children, adults, whatever." Or, "That's one way to address it for some people. But you're right, all economic classes, whether you're white, black, whatever."
“嗯，我认为洛威尔·魏克可能在美国国会为这个国家的残疾人、儿童、成人，无论是什么，做了更多的事情。”或者，“那是对待某些人的一种方式。但你是对的，所有经济阶层，无论你是白人、黑人，无论是什么。”
The hint here, Andrew Sullivan writes, is that Bob Dole knows he's reciting a list of groups that he should feel deeply sincere about. But he can't at that moment feel completely sincere about them. So he gently undercuts the blather he's required to express by adding the W word.
安德鲁·沙利文写道，这里的暗示是，鲍勃·多尔知道他正在背诵一份他应该感到深切真诚的群体名单。但他此刻无法对他们感到完全真诚。所以他通过加入那个“无”字，温和地削弱了他必须表达的废话。
We know he's in favor of helping the poor, underprivileged, disabled, veterans, whomever. But we also know he's not exactly smitten with empathy for their plight as he utters the words. He cares, but with an understandable and often funny level of detachment.
我们知道他支持帮助穷人、弱势群体、残疾人、退伍军人，无论谁。但我们也知道，当他说出这些词时，他并不是真的对他们的困境充满同情。他在关心，但带着一种可以理解且通常很有趣的超脱感。
Compare with Clinton. A "whatever" barely passes the president's lips. There is nary a scintilla of detachment from his sympathy for everyone and anyone at all times, and indeed a fear, even panic, that anyone might suspect otherwise. Dole is different.
与克林顿相比。一个“无所谓”几乎很难从总统口中溜出来。他对每个人和任何人时刻的同情几乎没有一丝超脱，事实上是一种恐惧，甚至是恐慌，担心有人会怀疑并非如此。多尔不同。
Sullivan goes on in a little section of this to argue that this ironic distance is actually something admirable, in a certain way. He quotes a couple more examples of him saying "whatever" in different situations. He says, "There are signs that Dole is aware of the complete silliness of much of what passes for political ritual. He knows that the throngs cheering for him today will be cheering for someone else tomorrow, that enthusiasm is fickle, that real support for someone like him always has something completely contingent about it. So he condescends to it under his breath in a throwaway, that wistful grin snickering up his face toward his black, darting eyes.
沙利文在文章的一小部分里继续论证说，这种讽刺的距离实际上在某种程度上是值得钦佩的。他引用了更多他在不同情况下说“无所谓”的例子。他说：“有迹象表明，多尔意识到了许多被当作政治仪式的东西的完全愚蠢。他知道今天为他欢呼的群众明天会为别人欢呼，热情是反复无常的，对像他这样的人的真正支持总是有某种完全偶然的东西。所以他以一种轻描淡写的方式，带着那张向他漆黑、敏锐的眼睛斜视的苦涩微笑，对这一切进行了屈尊降贵。”
Like the members of Generation X, Dole is post-just-about-everything. The difference, of course, is that he lived through it, and they were born after it. Dole, it's clear, has few illusions about the world. He's seen white-shirted revolutionaries have their moment and leave nothing but a deficit behind. His irony is not, as some boomers would have it, an expression of ennui or listlessness or cynicism. It's the sanest response to the real world, if you'll pardon the expression.
像X世代的成员一样，多尔是后一切主义者。当然，区别在于他经历过，而他们是在那之后出生的。很明显，多尔对世界没什么幻想。他见过穿白衬衫的革命者有过他们的时刻，除了留下赤字外什么都没留下。他的讽刺不是像一些婴儿潮一代所认为的那样，是厌倦、无精打采或愤世嫉俗的表达。这是对现实世界的理智回应，如果请原谅这个表达的话。
Members of Generation X, despite the fashionable assumption, are not disillusioned. They're merely un-illusioned. Their wariness is endemic. Dole gets this. Clinton never will."
X世代的成员，尽管有时尚的假设，并不是幻灭了。他们只是没有幻觉。他们的谨慎是地方性的。多尔明白这一点。克林顿永远不会。
Anyway, that's by Andrew Sullivan. Let's go to more of my Michael Lewis's campaign diaries.
无论如何，那是安德鲁·沙利文写的。让我们转到我的迈克尔·刘易斯的竞选日记。
February 19. The act, I should say, is always the same. The announcer brings on stage, one at a time, all the politicians who have endorsed Dole. They race out onto the stage like ballplayers before a game. Dole waits in the background until the crowd reaches a low fever pitch. A quick squirt of the breath spray, and he's on.
2月19日。我得说，过程总是一样的。主持人一个接一个地把支持多尔的政治家带上舞台。他们像比赛前的球手一样冲上舞台。多尔在背景中等待，直到人群达到低潮的狂热。喷了一点清新剂，他就上场了。
He stands at the podium with his left foot and left side jutted forward, though he's right-handed. His crippled right hand rests on the podium, but it's not a prop. He'll start in with something self-deprecating. "That's a lot better than the speech is going to be." Something like that.
他左脚和左侧向前突出地站在讲台上，尽管他是右撇子。他残疾的右手放在讲台上，但这不是道具。他会从某种自嘲开始。“这比接下来的演讲要好多了。”之类的话。
Presently, the voice of Dole emanates from the Milford, New Hampshire, town hall's facade. It's not so much a speech as a series of disconnected phrases uttered in an elegiac tone, some of which cause the people around me to break out into giggles. "Like everyone else in this room, I was born," Dole says. A Dole speech sounds like the sort of thing a red brick building would say if a red brick building could speak.
很快，多尔的声音从米尔福德新罕布什尔州市政厅的立面散发出来。这与其说是演讲，不如说是以忧郁语气说出的一系列不连贯的短语，其中一些引起我周围的人咯咯笑。“像这个房间里的每个人一样，我出生了，”多尔说。多尔的演讲听起来像红砖建筑如果会说话的话会说的那种话。
He pulls the rhythms of his "one America" refrain up short, just as it starts to flow. "We're not rich. We're not poor. We're not urban. We're not rural. We're not black. We're not white. You can go on and on and on." I have a dream, kind of. And gentleman in England now abed, well, I don't know. Maybe they should just get up.
他把“同一个美国”副歌的节奏拉得很短，就在它开始流动时。“我们不富有。我们不贫穷。我们不是城市。我们不是农村。我们不是黑人。我们不是白人。你可以没完没了地说下去。”我有一个梦想，某种程度上。英国的绅士们现在睡觉了，嗯，我不知道。也许他们应该起床。
It is more like the Cliff Notes of a great speech than the speech itself. The only lines Dole can deliver with any kind of strength sound like they were cribbed from Robert's Rules of Order. "Start the hearings. Go through the process. Do it in an orderly way."
这更像是伟大演讲的简纲，而不是演讲本身。多尔能有力地表达出来的唯一几行台词听起来像是抄袭自《罗伯特议事规则》。“开始听证会。走完程序。以有序的方式做。”
The whole time Dole is speaking, it is as if he is saying, "This is the speech I would give to you if I was the sort of person who gives speeches." I'm not sure whether Dole is actually modest or simply embarrassed by immodesty. I leave thinking that a man like this runs for the presidency not because he thinks he should be president. He thinks no one else should be president, so it might as well be him.
多尔说话的整个过程，就好像他在说：“如果我是那种会发表演讲的人，这就是我会给你们的演讲。”我不确定多尔是真正的谦虚，还是只是对不谦虚感到尴尬。我离开时心想，像这样的人竞选总统不是因为他认为他应该成为总统。他认为没有人应该成为总统，所以最好是他。
May 27. You never saw a more unhappy-looking group than the journalists assigned to follow Dole into New Jersey on Memorial Day. "I got the best seat in the house to the worst show in town," rumbles a cameraman as we board the plane at National Airport. "I just came in case he got shot or something," says a reporter, who doesn't even bother to take notes.
5月27日。你从未见过比被指派在阵亡将士纪念日跟随多尔去新泽西州的记者们更不快乐的群体了。“我坐在镇上最糟糕的演出的最佳座位上，”我们登上国家机场的飞机时，一位摄影师抱怨道。“我来只是以防他被枪击什么的，”一位连笔记都懒得记的记者说。
I, too, have my misgivings. Usually, my campaign notebooks are crammed with anecdotes, observations, and incidents. Whenever I'm with Dole, however, they simply refuse to fill up. The Dole campaign remains an arid, sterile place. Not much grows there.
我也有我的顾虑。通常，我的竞选笔记里挤满了轶事、观察和事件。然而，每当我和多尔在一起时，它们就是填不满。多尔的竞选活动仍然是一个干旱、无菌的地方。那里长不出什么东西。
Today is a kind of prelude to the general campaign, which will be relaunched in earnest tomorrow with a bold journey across the country. Dole marches for a dozen blocks through Clifton, New Jersey, in front of the parade's single float, bookended by his wife, Elizabeth, and Governor Christie Todd Whitman. The crowd is quiet and sparse, less than one deep.
今天是整体竞选活动的前奏，明天将以一次穿越全国的大胆旅程重新启动。多尔穿过新泽西州克利夫顿十几个街区，在游行的唯一花车前行进，由他的妻子伊丽莎白和克里斯蒂·托德·惠特曼州长左右护卫。人群安静且稀疏，不到一层。
The parade climaxes in a park, where Dole is meant to make a few remarks and lay a wreath on a symbolic grave site. I wait there for him, watching members of the local veterans organization subtly jockey for position. Six old men form the color guard, dressed in red jackets, VFW caps covered with patches and buttons, and the apprehensive air of people who fear they might be asked to improvise.
游行在公园里达到高潮，多尔在那里进行一些简短的致辞并在象征性的坟墓上献花圈。我在那里等他，看着当地退伍军人组织的成员微妙地争夺位置。六个老人组成了仪仗队，穿着红夹克，戴着布满补丁和徽章的海外战争退伍军人帽，带着担心可能被要求即兴发挥的人的那种不安神情。
But the really striking thing about them is how old they look, at least compared to Dole. They could almost be a different generation. "Any veterans of the first World War here?" I ask. "We just buried our last one last fall," says one, who sports a POW-MIA pin in his cap. "Don't come around here 10 years from now," says the man beside him, "or we won't be here, either."
但真正令人震惊的是他们看起来有多老，至少与多尔相比。他们几乎可以是不同的一代。“这里有第一次世界大战的退伍军人吗？”我问。“我们去年秋天刚刚埋葬了最后一位，”一位帽檐上戴着POW-MIA徽章的人说。“10年后再来这里，”他旁边的人说，“否则我们也就不在这里了。”
May 28. It turns out that we are flying all the way across the country to spend less than 24 hours in California before picking up and flying back. First to Chicago, where we'll spend tomorrow night, and then to Ohio, on May the 28th, five months before the election. The only reason it doesn't seem insane is that several hundred seemingly sober men in dark suits follow Dole wherever he goes. There is a kind of ambitious young person who mistakes frenetic movement for advancement in the world. They'll call you from the road and say, "I'm in Bangladesh on business, heading for Iceland." And you know that he thinks this is sufficient explanation of his purpose in life.
5月28日。结果我们飞了全国，在加利福尼亚待了不到24小时就飞回来。先是芝加哥，明天晚上我们在那里，然后是5月28日，选举前五个月到俄亥俄州。它看起来不疯狂的唯一原因是，数百名看似清醒的穿深色西装的男人跟着多尔走到哪里。有一种雄心勃勃的年轻人，误把疯狂的移动当成在世界上的进步。他们会从路上给你打电话说，“我在孟加拉国出差，正前往冰岛。”你知道他认为这就是对自己人生目的的充分解释。
The Dole campaign has something of this feeling. As long as the candidate keeps moving, everyone traveling with him is exempt from serious self-examination. Which is a shame, since they have no idea why they are doing what they are doing. It's frequent flyer politics.
多尔的竞选活动有这种感觉。只要候选人不停下来，所有随行人员都可以免于严肃的自我审视。这是一个遗憾，因为他们根本不知道为什么要这样做。这是飞行常客政治。
And within a couple of hours, I'm having my first Admiral Stockdale moment. Who am I? What am I doing here?
几个小时之内，我第一次有了海军上将斯托克代尔的时刻。我是谁？我在这里做什么？
Early the second morning, we descend, in our motorcade of 13 cars and 2 buses, on a seemingly tranquil park in Redondo Beach. The point of the event and the trip is to illustrate that Dole is against crime. The trouble is that Clinton is against crime, too. So Dole needs to show that he's more fervently against crime than Clinton, who at this very moment is on route to New Orleans to deliver his own anti-crime speech. Dole and Clinton are like Time and Newsweek. No matter how much they claim to differ, they still run the same covers, week after week.
第二天一早，我们在13辆车和2辆巴士组成的车队中，降临在雷东多海滩一个看似宁静的公园里。这次活动和旅行的目的是为了说明多尔反对犯罪。问题是克林顿也反对犯罪。所以多尔需要证明他比克林顿更热烈地反对犯罪，而克林顿此刻正在前往新奥尔良的路上发表他自己的反犯罪演讲。多尔和克林顿就像《时代》和《新闻周刊》。无论他们声称有多大不同，他们每周仍然运行相同的封面。
The park is being celebrated as an example of a neighborhood reclaiming public space from urban violence. But as various political dignitaries loudly disapprove of drive-by shootings, a small group of dissenters forms on the fringe. All but one are the Hispanics who bear the brunt of the new anti-crime esprit. They're hauled off to jail for all sorts of odd crimes, carrying baseball bats into the park after 7 o'clock in the evening, for instance.
这个公园被当作社区从城市暴力中夺回公共空间的一个例子来庆祝。但当各种政治显贵们大声谴责驾车枪击事件时，在边缘形成了一小群异议人士。除一人外，所有人都是承受新反犯罪精神重压的拉美裔。他们因各种奇怪的犯罪被送进监狱，例如晚上7点后带着棒球棒进入公园。
The exception is a gentle old soul named Art Campbell, who for decades has cleaned the park, coached the local kids, and groomed the playing fields. The ball field at the center of the park is named for him. Art Campbell is a Dole supporter. "I'm for the man," he says. "I don't go by the party." But he's mildly perplexed by the anti-crime rally. "It isn't as bad as all that," he says.
例外是一个叫阿特·坎贝尔的温柔灵魂，几十年来他一直打扫这个公园，指导当地孩子，并维护运动场。公园中心的球场以他的名字命名。阿特·坎贝尔是多尔的支持者。“我支持这个人，”他说。“我不看政党。”但他对反犯罪集会感到有点困惑。“没那么糟糕，”他说。
A policeman on the scene confirms that the crime statistics in Redondo Beach are in line with those of the nation as a whole. Violent crime has declined steadily here, as it has in other cities, over the past 20 years. More to the point, he cannot recall a single violent crime in the park. "A few years ago, someone shot a gun in the air as he drove past the park," he says, "But no one was hurt."
现场的一名警察证实，雷东多海滩的犯罪统计数据与全国作为一个整体一致。暴力犯罪在这里一直在下降，正如在其他城市过去20年里一样。更重要的是，他不记得公园里发生过一起暴力犯罪。“几年前，有人开车经过公园时朝天开了一枪，”他说，“但没有人受伤。”
Campbell stops the park custodian, a Hispanic man who speaks poor English. "Do you think this Dole thing is a good idea?" he asks the man. The man takes one look at my notepad and says, "I no want to say." He's afraid of offending his employers. The greatest fear in the park is the fear of offending the people on the platform who are spearheading the anti-crime initiative.
坎贝尔拦住公园管理员，一个英语很差的拉美裔男人。“你觉得这个多尔的事情是个好主意吗？”他问那个男人。男人看了一眼我的记事本说，“我不想说。”他害怕冒犯他的雇主。公园里最大的恐惧是冒犯讲台上那些领导反犯罪倡议的人。
Having successfully fed, and fed off of, the fear of crime, we wearily board the bus. I am now certain that nothing interesting will ever occur in the close-cropped frame of the staged Dole event. Where do politics come from, anyway? Not from listening to Bob Dole deliver a speech written by someone else to a group of people he knows nothing about in a place to which he'll never return.
成功地喂养了对犯罪的恐惧，并从这种恐惧中获益后，我们疲惫地上了巴士。我现在确信，在 staging 的多尔活动的狭窄框架内，永远不会发生任何有趣的事情。政治究竟来自哪里？不是听鲍勃·多尔发表别人写的演讲，对着一群他一无所知的人，在一个他永远不会回去的地方。
Many of the criticisms about Dole can be made of Clinton, too, of course. You can't say anything about Dole's use of push polls, or about the cynicism of his staged events, without having some seasoned reporter look at you as if you were a child and say, "So what? They all do that."
当然，对多尔的许多批评也可以针对克林顿。你不能说任何关于多尔使用推波助澜的民调，或关于他 staging 活动的愤世嫉俗的话，而不让某个经验丰富的记者像看孩子一样看着你说，“那又怎样？他们都那样。”
The next week, the New York Times will carry a putatively positive piece about Dole's campaign manager, Scott Reed. Toward the end of it, almost by-the-by, we read this astonishing revelation about Dole's senate resignation. Quote, "The element of surprise was essential, Mr. Dole and Reed decided, if the announcement were to appear bold and make an impression on voters. 'If it had leaked,' Mr. Reed said, 'he probably wouldn't have done it.'"
接下来的一周，《纽约时报》将刊登一篇据称是关于多尔竞选经理斯科特·里德的正面文章。在那篇文章快结束时，几乎是顺带一提，我们读到了关于多尔参议院辞职的这个惊人的揭露。引用，“惊喜的因素是必不可少的，多尔先生和里德决定，如果公告要显得大胆并给选民留下印象。‘如果泄露了，’里德先生说，‘他可能就不会这么做了。’”
Think of it. Just a few weeks ago, the man stood before us and brought tears to our eyes by saying that you do not lay claim to the office you hold. It lays claim to you. Your obligation is to bring to it the gifts you can, of labor and honesty, and then to part with grace.
想想看。就在几周前，这个人站在我们面前，说你不占有你拥有的职位，是它占有了你，让我们的眼睛湿润了。你的义务是带来你能带来的天赋，劳动和诚实，然后优雅地离开。
But according to Reed, Dole's decision to end his wonderful senate career was baldly conceived as a PR stunt. Journalists are often accused of being cynical. But the cynicism of journalists does not compare to that of serious presidential candidates.
但根据里德的说法，多尔结束他美好参议院生涯的决定仅仅被构想为一个公关噱头。记者常被指责为愤世嫉俗。但记者的愤世嫉俗无法与严肃总统候选人的愤世嫉俗相比。
Michael Lewis. His campaign diaries can be read in The New Republic. He's the author of Liar's Poker , which is a really funny, interesting, wonderful book that we strongly recommend. Coming up, how you, you, can imitate Dole for your friends and family, and Mr. Danny Drennan. That's all in a minute when our program continues.
迈克尔·刘易斯。他的竞选日记可以在《新共和》中读到。他是《说谎者的扑克》的作者，这是一本非常有趣、引人入胜、精彩的书，我们强烈推荐。即将到来，你，你，可以如何为你的朋友和家人模仿多尔，以及丹尼·德雷南先生。那都在一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a subject and invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that subject with a variety of different kinds of stories. Today, our topic is Bob Dole. We've arrived now at act two of our program. Act Two, How You Can Be Bob Dole.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过各种不同类型的故事来探讨这个主题。今天，我们的主题是鲍勃·多尔。我们现在到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，如何成为鲍勃·多尔。
For this act of our show, we welcome to our show a man named Robert Smigel. And Smigel impersonates Bob Dole on Late Night with Conan O'Brien. He used to impersonate him on the Dana Carvey Show, a short-lived program. Smigel himself is former head writer with Saturday Night Live. And he's probably best known for a sketch that he created.
对于我们节目的这一幕，我们欢迎一位名叫罗伯特·斯密格尔的人来到我们的节目。斯密格尔在《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》中模仿鲍勃·多尔。他曾经在达纳·卡维秀这个寿命很短的节目中模仿他。斯密格尔本人是《周六夜现场》的前首席编剧。他最出名的可能是他创作的一个小品。
To describe this thing, it's one of these things, it's almost hard to believe that a single person came up with this idea. Because it's just one of those things that just seem to spring out of the collective unconscious of our nation. This is a sketch that on Saturday Night Live , they called the Superfans. It was a bunch of Chicago, Chi-caw-go, guys, big guys, who would talk about Da Bears, Da Bulls.
要描述这个东西，它是其中之一，几乎难以相信单个人能想出这个主意。因为它只是那些似乎从我们国家的集体无意识中涌现出来的东西之一。这是《周六夜现场》里的一个小品，他们称之为超级粉丝。这是一群芝加哥人，大家伙，谈论熊队，公牛队。
My tombstone will say "Da Corpse," I think.
我的墓碑上会写着“尸体”，我想。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Anyway, so at some point, it became clear that Smigel was going to be the person who was going to be imitating Bob Dole on the Conan O'Brien show. And by the way, when he does this, what appears on a screen, there's sort of a TV monitor comes down from the ceiling. And then Conan O'Brien talks to the monitor. And on the monitor, you'll see a photograph of Dole.
无论如何，在某个时候，很明显斯密格尔将成为那个要在柯南·奥布莱恩秀上模仿鲍勃·多尔的人。顺便说一句，当他这样做时，屏幕上会出现什么，有一种电视监视器从天花板上降下来。然后柯南·奥布莱恩对着监视器说话。而在监视器上，你会看到一张多尔的照片。
And then the lips are chroma keyed out or something, so you don't see those lips. What you see is Smigel's lips. And then he does Dole's voice.
然后嘴唇被色度键控抠掉或什么的，所以你看不见那些嘴唇。你看到的是斯密格尔的嘴唇。然后他做多尔的声音。
So when it became clear that he was going to have to imitate Bob Dole, he set about to design. He had to think about it. He had to plan it.
所以当很明显他将不得不模仿鲍勃·多尔时，他开始设计。他不得不思考它。他不得不计划它。
Instantly, I thought of Dan Aykroyd's impression, which was ingrained in my head from working at Saturday Night Live. And what I try to do is find something and take it further, because otherwise, it's just boring to do what Dan Aykroyd did. And so I started with the monotone thing. It's sort of how you have to get into it is just, "Bob Dole. Bob Dole pronounces, emphasizes every word about the same way. It's kind of like a test pattern, [? Dooooole. ?] That kind of thing."
瞬间，我想到了丹·艾克罗伊德的印象，它因为在《周六夜现场》工作而根深蒂固地留在我的脑海里。我尝试做的是找到某种东西并更进一步，因为否则，做丹·艾克罗伊德所做的只是无聊。所以我从单调的事情开始。它是你必须进入它的某种方式只是，“鲍勃·多尔。鲍勃·多尔发音，强调每个词的方式都一样。它有点像测试图案，[？多——尔。？]那种东西。”
And Dan Aykroyd kind of does the bully Dole from the '70s. Dole back then was sort of a Nixon protege. And then I figured I'd take it a little further and make it a little munchkin-like.
丹·艾克罗伊德那种模仿的是70年代的恶霸多尔。那时的多尔是尼克松的门徒。然后我想我应该更进一步，让他有点像个矮人。
"Because Bob Dole tends to, when he rolls, when he keeps going, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], you'll be hist-- you'll be hist-- you'll be history." That kind of thing. Then I figured out that Bob Dole is actually the tree from The Wizard of Oz. He's not a munchkin. He's actually--
“因为鲍勃·多尔倾向于，当他滚动时，当他继续前进时，[听不清]，你将是历——你将是历——你将是历史。”那种东西。然后我发现鲍勃·多尔实际上是《绿野仙踪》里的树。他不是矮人。他实际上是——
Wait, let's pause on the munchkin. What is the quality that makes it munchkin-like.
等等，让我们在矮人这件事上停一下。矮人的质量是什么，让它看起来像矮人。
Mayor of Munchkinland, you know. "And she's not really, really dead. She's really most sincerely dead." Kind of sounds like Bob Dole. "Not really-diddily dead. She's really-- let me tell you something. Bill Clinton's campaign is dead."
矮人国的市长，你知道的。“她并没有真正死掉。她真的最诚挚地死掉了。”听起来有点像鲍勃·多尔。“不是真正的-迪迪死了。她真的——让我告诉你一件事。比尔·克林顿的竞选活动死掉了。”
But anyway, what he's really like is The Wizard of Oz tree, which is, "I'm Bob Dole. How'd you like it if somebody took apples off of you?"
但无论如何，他真正像的是《绿野仙踪》里的树，也就是，“我是鲍勃·多尔。如果有人从你身上拿苹果，你觉得怎么样？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know, he's even got the same expression as the tree. And he's tragic in the way the tree is. People are constantly pulling apples off, and they're not tasting them. I've got about five minutes more on this analogy.
你知道，他甚至有和树一样的表情。而且他像树一样是悲剧性的。人们不断地在拉苹果，而且他们没有尝尝它们。关于这个类比，我还有五分钟要说。
Yeah, keep going.
是啊，继续。
Pshaw. Nonsense, Conan O'Brien. Now you listen to me. Bob Dole wasn't last night. Bob Dole's the new president of the United States, that's right.
呸。胡说，柯南·奥布莱恩。现在你听我说。鲍勃·多尔不是昨天。鲍勃·多尔是美国的新总统，没错。
Dole's on a roll. Dole topped the polls. That's right. Dole's in control. Dole's riding a bull-Dole-zer. Shoot that punk. Shoot that punk, smoke that Dole.
多尔在滚动。多尔在民调中名列前茅。没错。多尔在控制。多尔正在骑一头公牛-多尔-推土机。射击那个混蛋。射击那个混蛋，抽那根多尔烟。
There's actually something kind of sweet about your imitation of Dole on Conan, because he's always a little bit giddy.
事实上，你在柯南秀上对多尔的模仿有一种甜蜜的东西，因为他总是有点得意洋洋。
On Conan? Yeah.
在柯南秀上？是啊。
He almost seems deliriously happy.
他似乎几乎高兴得神魂颠倒。
Oh, well, I'm just imagining his deepest thoughts. And he's just letting them out at 12:30 at night, when no one's watching. That's sort of the premise. Like, "Bob Dole's the next president of the United States. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Sing with me, O'Brien." And I would make him sing, you know, "Happy Happy Dole Dole."
哦，好吧，我只是在想象他内心深处的想法。而他只是在晚上12点半，没人看的时候把它们放出来。这算是前提。就像，“鲍勃·多尔是美国下一任总统。[听不清]。跟我一起唱，奥布莱恩。”我会让他唱歌，你知道，“快乐快乐多尔多尔。”
--Dole de-Dole de-Dole.
——多尔-得-多尔-得-多尔。
Wait a minute, Max, Max.
等等，麦克斯，麦克斯。
Dole de-Dole, Dole de-Dole. Dole-de--
多尔-得-多尔，多尔-得-多尔。多尔-得——
Those are the stupidest lyrics I've ever heard.
那是听过最愚蠢的歌词。
Dole.
多尔。
The thing about it that's so appealing is that it shows Dole taking pleasure in something in a way that we never get to see him do in real life.
它如此吸引人的地方在于，它展示了多尔以一种我们在现实生活中从未见过的方式从某事中获得乐趣。
When I do a politician on that show, I'm almost always doing the id of that politician. It's basically nonsense. And sometimes I just have Dole giggling, and just--
当我在那个节目上做一个政治家时，我几乎总是做那个政治家的本我。它基本上是无稽之谈。有时我只是让多尔咯咯笑，只是——
"Bow to me" is one of my favorite things.
“向我鞠躬”是我最喜欢的东西之一。
Bow down to me, Conan O'Brien. Bow down to the next senate majority leader, most powerful man in the world.
向我鞠躬，柯南·奥布莱恩。向下一任参议院多数党领袖，世界上最有权势的人鞠躬。
Do you feel a certain affection and closeness for Dole? I would think actually imitating somebody, you would have to develop that.
你对多尔有一种特定的感情和亲近感吗？我本以为模仿某人，你必须培养那种感情。
Yeah, I really-- it's hard not to like Bob Dole anyway. I mostly feel sorry for him. To me, it just seems like it's only going to get worse for Bob Dole. At the point where he's supposed to catch up, where everybody expects that it's going to tighten, that's when they're going to debate. And Bob Dole needs to have a 20-point lead before they start debating.
是啊，我真的——无论如何很难不喜欢鲍勃·多尔。我大多为他感到难过。对我来说，看起来这对鲍勃·多尔只会变得更糟。在应该赶上的时刻，在每个人都预期会变得更紧的时候，那正是他们要辩论的时候。鲍勃·多尔需要在辩论开始前有20个百分点的领先优势。
Do you do him sometimes around the house?
你有时在家里模仿他吗？
Unconsciously, yeah, sometimes. I just got a puppy, and I find it very effective training.
无意识地，是的，有时。我刚养了一只小狗，我发现这在训练上非常有效。
Really, like how?
真的，怎么个有效法？
Very effective, just when I put on the Bob Dole voice at the puppy. "Sit! You listen to me, puppy. You poop."
非常有效，只是当我用鲍勃·多尔的声音对着小狗时。“坐下！你听我说，小狗。你拉屎。”
If you've seen Robert Smigel's imitations on the Dana Carvey Show , and actually, apparently, not many of you have, because that show did not last very long on the television, Smigel's imitation on that show was kind of cruel to Dole. He basically played Dole as this doddering old man who could barely string together two or three words in a sentence.
如果你看过罗伯特·斯密格尔在达纳·卡维秀上的模仿，而且显然，你们中没多少人看过，因为那个节目在电视上没持续多久，斯密格尔在那个节目上的模仿对多尔来说有点残酷。他基本上把多尔演成了一个步履蹒跚的老人，在句子中几乎无法连贯地把两三个词串在一起。
And in this imitation, in this version of his imitation, periodically, Dole would just lose it. He would just forget where he is and what was going on. In one sketch, Smigel actually has Bob Dole going around saying, "Why won't Bob Dole debate me?"
而在这种模仿中，在这个模仿版本中，多尔会定期失去控制。他会忘记他在哪里，发生了什么事。在一个小品中，斯密格尔实际上让鲍勃·多尔到处说，“为什么鲍勃·多尔不跟我辩论？”
That's right. That's how I used the Bob Dole thing there. He's lost track of who Bob Dole is. "Why won't Bob Dole debate me? Bob Dole is hiding. Somebody--" And then he turned around and started yelling at the people behind him, like he thought they were the audience all the sudden.
没错。这就是我在那里使用鲍勃·多尔的东西的方式。他已经忘记了鲍勃·多尔是谁。“为什么鲍勃·多尔不跟我辩论？鲍勃·多尔在躲藏。有人——”然后他转过身，开始对着身后的人大喊大叫，就好像他突然以为他们是观众一样。
As somebody who has done an imitation of Dole where he's the boisterous, slightly bullying with Conan, the "bow to me" Dole, what do you make of this whole kinder, gentler, personable, "I'm going to tell you my real story," how do you think it's coming off? You think it's working?
作为一个曾经模仿过多尔是那种喧闹的，柯南秀上那种稍微欺凌的，“向我鞠躬”多尔的人，你觉得这一切更友善、更温和、更风度翩翩，“我要告诉你我的真实故事”怎么看？你觉得它在起作用吗？
Well, we've made fun of that on the Conan show, too, you know.
嗯，我们在柯南秀上也拿这个开过玩笑，你知道。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Well, we've segued from him going, "I tell you, Bill Clinton's going to jail. Hillary Clinton's going to jail. Socks the cat's going to jail. Oh, what am I talking about? What's happening to Dole?
是啊。嗯，我们从他走向，“我告诉你，比尔·克林顿要进监狱。希拉里·克林顿要进监狱。袜子猫要进监狱。哦，我在说什么？多尔发生了什么？
Like that, O'Brien? That's a new Dole. New Dole cries. New Dole cries. Boo-hoo. Like it?" This man has cried more-- I don't think there's a politician who's cried in public more than Bob Dole. It's such an amazing flip side to the guy, who's looked down as such a hardass.
像那样，奥布莱恩？这是新的多尔。新的多尔哭了。新的多尔哭了。呜呜。喜欢吗？”这个人哭得更多——我不认为有任何政治家在公开场合比鲍勃·多尔哭得更多。对于那个被视为硬汉的家伙来说，这真是一个令人惊奇的另一面。
Wait, when has he cried? Let's list the times. There's at Nixon's funeral, right?
等等，他什么时候哭的？让我们列出这些时间。在尼克松的葬礼上，对吧？
Nixon's funeral. He cried in Russell, Kansas. He cried a little bit when he announced his resignation this year from the senate. And he cried when he went to Russell, Kansas. I mean, that's twice this spring. And then he cried at Nixon's funeral.
尼克松的葬礼。他在拉塞尔，堪萨斯州哭了。他在今年宣布辞去参议院职务时哭了一点点。他在去拉塞尔，堪萨斯州时哭了。我的意思是，今年春天两次了。然后他在尼克松的葬礼上哭了。
And do you buy it?
你相信吗？
Do I buy it? Yeah. Well, I buy the Nixon's funeral one. There didn't seem to be any political upside in that one.
我相信吗？是啊。嗯，我相信尼克松葬礼那次。那次看起来没有任何政治上的好处。
Yeah, that's true.
是啊，那是真的。
So if you buy that one, then you have to think that it's possible that he was sincere in the other two. I can imagine the senate one would be hard for him. The Russell, Kansas thing, that stretches credibility a little bit. Because basically, he only goes to Russell, Kansas to cry. Supposedly he's never there except to make a speech once every eight years, when he runs for president.
所以如果你相信那一次，那么你必须认为他在其他两次是真诚的可能性。我可以想象参议院那次对他来说很难。拉塞尔，堪萨斯那件事，稍微有点挑战可信度。因为基本上，他只在哭的时候才去拉塞尔，堪萨斯。据推测，他从不去那里，除非每八年竞选总统时发表一次演讲。
It's actually an odd thing to have a place where you go to cry. You know what I mean? What if every time you wanted to cry, you had to hop the train to Newark?
事实上，有一个你专门去哭的地方是一件奇怪的事情。你知道我的意思吗？如果每次你想哭时，你都必须赶火车去纽瓦克呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It could be a burden on a relationship, for one thing.
首先，这可能会成为人际关系的负担。
Got to go to Russell. Oh my god, I'm feeling a little bummed.
必须去拉塞尔。天哪，我感觉有点沮丧。
So let me ask you, do you have any tips for our listeners who might want to be imitating either candidate during the coming months?
所以让我问你，你对我们的听众有什么建议吗？他们可能在未来几个月想模仿任何一位候选人？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Just a couple of pointers on how they might handle it. Give us a couple for Clinton and a couple for Dole.
关于他们如何处理这个问题，只需要几个指针。给我们几个克林顿的，几个多尔的。
You mean just physical moves?
你的意思是只是身体动作？
Yeah, physical moves, sure.
是啊，身体动作，当然。
All right. Well, Bob Dole, I sort of walked you through Bob Dole. Start with the test pattern, "Nnnnn."
好的。嗯，鲍勃·多尔，我算是在鲍勃·多尔上引导你了。从测试图案开始，“嗯。”
The monotone.
单调。
"Dole, and everything is monotone after that. And he says the same thing in the same tone of voice, speaks very rapidly, Dole." And then putting an "Nn" before the Dole makes him seem older. "Nn-Dole," that kind of thing.
“多尔，之后的一切都是单调的。他用同样的语调说同样的话，说得非常快，多尔。”然后在多尔之前加一个“嗯”，让他显得更老。“嗯-多尔”，那种东西。
Clinton, any tips for Clinton?
克林顿，对克林顿有什么建议吗？
Well, it depends on how far you want to take one. If you want to do the crazy Clinton, then that's easy. You start with Bruce Springsteen.
嗯，这取决于你想走多远。如果你想做疯狂的克林顿，那么这很容易。你从布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀开始。
And it's just, "Hey, little Mary with your daddy home. Hey, man. How you doing? How's it going, everybody? Whee-haw."
“嘿，小玛丽，你爸爸在家。嘿，伙计。你好吗？大家都好吗？呜——哈。”
But then there's more of a-- the more accurate Clinton is kind of the caring guy who's just sort of a gentle thing. And it takes very little, very little energy. You just barely, barely breathe, hardly at all.
但之后有更多——更准确的克林顿是那种关心人的家伙，只是一种温柔的东西。它只需要很少，很少的能量。你几乎，几乎不呼吸，几乎一点都不呼吸。
You barely breathe. Also, your voice is going all the way to the back of your throat, isn't it?
你几乎不呼吸。而且你的声音一直传到喉咙后部，不是吗？
When I'm doing this, yeah. I feel the air. That's very good, yes. I feel the air pushing toward the back of my throat.
当我这样做时，是啊。我感觉到空气。非常好，是的。我感觉到空气推向喉咙后部。
Robert Smigel, he imitates Bob Dole still on the program Late Night with Conan O'Brien.
罗伯特·斯密格尔，他仍在《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》上模仿鲍勃·多尔。
Act Three, TV Politics. Most of us experience Bob Dole, the real Bob Dole, on television. Most of us actually experience most politics in this country through television. And we thought to discuss Bob Dole as a television figure, we would get somebody who writes about TV.
第三幕，电视政治。我们大多数人是在电视上体验鲍勃·多尔，真正的鲍勃·多尔。我们大多数人实际上是通过电视体验这个国家的绝大多数政治。我们想讨论作为电视人物的鲍勃·多尔，我们想邀请某位谈论电视的人。
And the person we got is a guy named Danny Drennan. And he writes something on the World Wide Web called the "90210 Weekly Wrapup." And this is about the TV show Beverly Hills 90210.
我们找到的那个人是一个叫丹尼·德雷南的人。他在万维网上写了一些东西，叫“90210周刊总结”。这是关于电视剧《飞越比弗利》的。
The way he writes about television, he is in his own genre of writing. He careens from sheer cattiness to his own analysis of the program and how it's produced and all the actors, and then what all that means for the nation as a whole. Periodically, he'll digress into little personal stories about his own life.
他谈论电视的方式，他属于他自己的一种写作类型。他从纯粹的刻薄走向对自己对节目及其制作方式和所有演员的分析，然后所有这一切对整个国家意味着什么。定期，他会跑题讲一些关于他自己生活的小个人故事。
And so we at this little radio show adore his writing. And in fact, if you want to visit his website, we recommend it. The address is www.inquisitor.com. He also publishes a zine called Inquisitor.
所以我们在这个小广播节目里崇拜他的写作。事实上，如果你想访问他的网站，我们推荐它。地址是www.inquisitor.com。他还出版了一本叫《调查者》的杂志。
Anyway, so we invited him, and we were really glad when he said yes. We invited him to do something for our show. We asked him to watch Bob and Elizabeth Dole when they appeared on a recent hour of Larry King Live.
无论如何，我们邀请了他，当他说愿意时我们真的很高兴。我们邀请他为我们的节目做些什么。我们请他观看鲍勃和伊丽莎白·多尔在最近一小时的《拉里·金直播》中的表现。
So I'm watching Larry King Live the other night, and Bob Dole is wearing a dark gray suit and a powerish, reddish tie. And Elizabeth Dole is wearing a blue, blue dress and Red Cross red lipstick, which I guess means she's going for that red, white, and blue effect. And the first question is about the statement made by somebody that Hillary should debate Elizabeth.
所以我那天晚上在看《拉里·金直播》，鲍勃·多尔穿着一套深灰色西装和一条偏权力的红色领带。伊丽莎白·多尔穿着一件蓝色、蓝色的裙子和红十字红色的口红，我想这意味着她正在追求那种红、白、蓝的效果。第一个问题是关于某人提出的希拉里应该和伊丽莎白辩论的声明。
And Bob Dole is like, "It was a joke." And Elizabeth Dole is like, "It was in jest, Larry." And then Elizabeth Dole goes on and on about how the emphasis should be on the presidential candidates, which is funny, because she doesn't let poor Bob Dole get a word in edgewise.
鲍勃·多尔说：“那是个玩笑。”伊丽莎白·多尔说：“那是戏言，拉里。”然后伊丽莎白·多尔滔滔不绝地谈论重点应该放在总统候选人身上，这很有趣，因为她根本不让可怜的鲍勃·多尔插上一句话。
So next, Larry King is asking whether there are any women on "the list" for vice president, since Elizabeth Dole said that in our lifetime, there would be women presidential candidates. And Bob Dole goes on and on about his process for picking a VP. And Larry King, sounding like someone out of The Godfather , is like, "But you know all of these guys. What do you need a process for?"
接下来，拉里·金在问副总统的名单上有没有女性，因为伊丽莎白·多尔说在我们有生之年会有女性总统候选人。鲍勃·多尔滔滔不绝地谈论他挑选副总统的过程。而拉里·金听起来像《教父》里的人，说：“但你认识所有这些人。你需要什么过程？”
And Bob Dole starts to list the things he looks for in a vice president. And two of them are health and age, which I thought kind of weird. Like maybe Bob Dole shouldn't be allowed to say the words health and age at all. And all I could imagine was a room full of Dole campaign handlers in Larry King's green room going "Damn!" at the top of their lungs.
鲍勃·多尔开始列举他寻找副总统的条件。其中两个是健康和年龄，我觉得这有点奇怪。就像也许鲍勃·多尔根本不应该被允许说健康和年龄这两个词一样。我能想象到的只是一个充满多尔竞选处理人员的拉里·金绿屋，对着嗓子眼大喊“该死！”
So then there's this whole thing about Katie Couric's interview of the Doles, and how she didn't stick to her script and just talk about the book that the Doles have written, which I guess was Elizabeth Dole's cue to start talking about the book, which she did. And she reads the inscription she wrote to Larry King, which goes "To Larry. Here's hoping that Larry King Live will be broadcast live from the Dole White House, 7-15-96. And your program is mentioned in the book, Larry."
所以接着是关于凯蒂·库里奇采访多尔夫妇的整件事，以及她没有按照她的剧本走，只是谈论多尔夫妇写的书，我想这应该是伊丽莎白·多尔开始谈论这本书的暗示，她也确实这么做了。她读了她写给拉里·金的题词，写着“致拉里。希望拉里·金直播能从多尔白宫现场直播，96年7月15日。而你的节目在书里提到了，拉里。”
I totally think that Elizabeth Dole is shaking down Larry King. Maybe he won't be interviewing the Gores or the Clintons because Elizabeth Dole gave him the plug in the book and that emphatic, sternly scolding "Larry" at the end. And then Larry King points his gatling gun mouth at Elizabeth, who, with a big old smile on her face, is like, "I thought we were there to talk about the book, Larry." Like, how harsh is Elizabeth Dole? I seriously would never want to be on Elizabeth Dole's bad side.
我完全认为伊丽莎白·多尔在敲诈拉里·金。也许他不会采访戈尔夫妇或克林顿夫妇，因为伊丽莎白·多尔在书里给了他广告，以及最后那句强调的、严厉责备的“拉里”。然后拉里·金把他的加特林机枪嘴对准伊丽莎白，她脸上带着一个灿烂的老笑容说：“我想我们是来谈论这本书的，拉里。”伊丽莎白·多尔有多刻薄？我真的永远不想站在伊丽莎白·多尔的对立面。
Next, they're going on and on about how badly the campaign is doing. And Elizabeth Dole is talking about how no one is engaged because it's summer vacation. And Larry King is all, "Well, you know the media. Today's mistake is tomorrow's headline." And how weird to hear Mr. Media Manipulation himself talk about the goings-on of the media as if they are a totally natural state of affairs that he himself has nothing to do with. How annoying is that?
接下来，他们滔滔不绝地谈论竞选活动做得多么糟糕。伊丽莎白·多尔谈论因为这是暑假，所以没有人参与。拉里·金说，“嗯，你知道媒体。今天的错误是明天的头条。”听到媒体操纵先生本人谈论媒体的所作所为，就好像它们完全是一种他本人与之无关的自然状态，是多么奇怪。那有多烦人？
And then Bob Dole, instead of casually dropping his buzzwords one by one into the conversation, just reels off a whole bunch of them wholesale. And meanwhile, Larry King is still stuck on the whole tax thing and is trying to pin Bob dole down. And I have to wonder whether Larry King has really bad breath or something, because Bob Dole kept making these faces as if that might be the case.
然后鲍勃·多尔没有把他的流行语一个接一个地随意抛入谈话中，而是批发式地抛出了一大堆。与此同时，拉里·金仍然卡在税收这件事上，并试图把鲍勃·多尔钉死。我不得不怀疑拉里·金是否真的有口臭什么的，因为鲍勃·多尔不停地做这些表情，就好像情况可能是这样。
So then Elizabeth Dole is talking about Bob Dole's message and Bob Dole's agenda, and then it's her turn to start reeling off a list of agenda bullet points. And then Bob Dole basically says that without television, a politician can't campaign, which is a pretty scary thing, if you ask me. And then he adds in all the bullet points of what Bill Clinton has done wrong so far. And then Bob Dole is saying how he's glad to be the underdog and that the real campaign is going to kick off with a powerful acceptance speech by Bob Dole at the Republican National Convention.
所以伊丽莎白·多尔在谈论鲍勃·多尔的信息和鲍勃·多尔的议程，然后轮到她开始滔滔不绝地列出一张议程要点清单。然后鲍勃·多尔基本上说没有电视，政治家就无法竞选，如果你问我，这是一件相当可怕的事情。然后他补充了比尔·克林顿到目前为止所做错的所有要点。然后鲍勃·多尔说他是多么高兴成为弱者，真正的竞选活动将以鲍勃·多尔在共和党全国代表大会上的有力接受演讲开始。
And then Bob Dole announces that Susan Molinari is going to be the keynote speaker, since she is young and dynamic. And Elizabeth Dole adds that Molinari believes strongly in what Bob Dole stands for. And it's almost at the point where if you couldn't see the TV picture, you might very well wonder if Bob Dole is still in the room or not, since everyone, including Bob Dole, keeps saying "Bob Dole."
然后鲍勃·多尔宣布苏珊·莫利纳里将成为主讲人，因为她年轻且充满活力。伊丽莎白·多尔补充说，莫利纳里坚定地相信鲍勃·多尔所代表的东西。这几乎到了如果你看不见电视画面，你很可能会怀疑鲍勃·多尔是否还在房间里，因为每个人，包括鲍勃·多尔，不停地说“鲍勃·多尔”。
Meanwhile, Larry King is milking the whole Susan Molinari thing. And he's like, "That's a big statement about cities." And Bob Dole adds women to that list. And then he starts going on and on about all this stuff he's done for women all these years.
与此同时，拉里·金正在挤压整个苏珊·莫利纳里的事情。他说：“那是关于城市的一个重大声明。”鲍勃·多尔把女性加到了那个名单里。然后他开始滔滔不绝地谈论他多年来为女性所做的一切。
And all I know is that I was taking the M7 uptown bus the other day, and we were going through Midtown. And there were these two women seated in front of me. And in Midtown, there's this big clock which shows a readout of the national debt getting higher and higher. And this one woman is like, "Look, the national debt just gets higher and higher." Like maybe they should take the money that everyone saves with MCI, which is another huge number readout in Midtown, and put that money toward paying off the national debt.
我所知道的只是我那天正在乘坐M7上行公交车，我们正在穿过中城。前面坐着两个女人。在中城，有一个巨大的时钟显示着国债越来越高的读数。这个女人说，“看，国债越来越高了。”就像也许他们应该把每个人通过MCI节省下来的钱（那是中城另一个巨大的数字读数）拿出来，把那笔钱用于偿还国债。
So then she asks her friend, "Who are you voting for?" And the second lady is like, "I don't like the situation we're in one bit. I don't see anyone with any high morals or good ideas, and I don't like Bob Dole. I don't like his stance on issues. Plus, I think he's too old."
所以她问她的朋友，“你投给谁？”第二个女士说，“我一点都不喜欢我们现在的处境。我没看到有任何具有崇高道德或好主意的人，而且我不喜欢鲍勃·多尔。我不喜欢他在议题上的立场。另外，我觉得他太老了。”
And the first lady's like "Too old." And the second lady is like, "Too old. He would be a one-term president." And the other lady is like, "Definitely a one-term president." So maybe Bob Dole should ride around on New York mass transit to get a sense of what he should be doing. And then Bob Dole goes on about what he's done for women, saying, "I've been living with a woman," which was a really, really weird thing to say.
第一个女士说，“太老了。”第二个女士说，“太老了。他会是个一届总统。”另一个女士说，“绝对的一届总统。”所以也许鲍勃·多尔应该乘坐纽约公共交通工具来了解他应该做什么。然后鲍勃·多尔谈论他为女性所做的事情，说，“我和一个女人住在一起，”这真是一句非常、非常奇怪的话。
So then we get an advertisement about health insurance sponsored by the Republican National Committee, showing this smirking kid breathing through a tube while his mother goes on about what we need. And then there's a commercial for life insurance featuring these crying statues in the rain. And I don't know that it's such a good idea to remind people about sickness and death when Bob Dole is on the program.
所以我们收到了一个由共和党全国委员会赞助的关于健康保险的广告，显示这个狞笑的孩子通过管子呼吸，而他的母亲滔滔不绝地谈论我们需要什么。然后是一个以雨中哭泣的雕像为特色的寿险广告。我不知道在鲍勃·多尔上节目时提醒人们生病和死亡是不是一个好主意。
And Larry King brings up Susan Molinari again, like, "Yeah, Larry, we get your little prearranged scoop. Quit working it so much." And Larry King is like, "How did you get involved in this tobacco thing?" And Bob Dole is like, "Just blew in, I guess." And then you realize that Bob Dole keeps looking at himself in the monitor, or else someone is there backstage that he's looking at for cues.
拉里·金再次提到了苏珊·莫利纳里，就像，“是啊，拉里，我们得到了你的预先安排的独家新闻。别再那么用力地运作它了。”拉里·金说，“你是怎么卷入这件烟草事情的？”鲍勃·多尔说，“大概只是吹进来的吧。”然后你意识到鲍勃·多尔不停地看着监视器里的自己，或者后台有人他正在看着寻求暗示。
And how sick is it to refer to the undeniable pull of tobacco company money in Bob Dole's pocket as something that "just blew in"? And then Bob Dole says he's not a scientist and so couldn't know that smoking is addictive, which is weird, because later he refers to relatives who were sick due to smoking-related problems. How much evidence do you personally need, Bob Dole?
把鲍勃·多尔口袋里不可否认的烟草公司金钱的拉力称为“只是吹进来的”是多么病态？然后鲍勃·多尔说他不是科学家，所以不知道吸烟会上瘾，这很奇怪，因为后来他提到因吸烟相关问题而生病的亲戚。你个人需要多少证据，鲍勃·多尔？
And then Larry King is like, "Would you tell Americans to stop smoking?" And Bob Dole is like, "Yeah, all of you stop smoking." And Elizabeth Dole qualifies that with "pregnant women and elderly people with respiratory disorders." Where do you think most respiratory disorders come from, Elizabeth Dole?
然后拉里·金说，“你会告诉美国人戒烟吗？”鲍勃·多尔说，“是啊，你们都戒烟。”伊丽莎白·多尔加上限定条件“孕妇和患有呼吸系统疾病的老年人。”你认为大多数呼吸系统疾病是从哪里来的，伊丽莎白·多尔？
And then Bob Dole is like, "It's not good for you. It's bad for your health. Don't do it." And having said that, like he was about to go on, but Elizabeth Dole interrupts him and goes, "That's it." And they all laugh. And we get an arthritis pain medication commercial and a denture cream commercial.
然后鲍勃·多尔说，“这对你没好处。这对你的健康有害。别做。”说了这些，就像他要继续一样，但伊丽莎白·多尔打断他说，“就这样。”他们都笑了。我们收到了一个关节炎止痛药广告和一个假牙膏广告。
So then Larry King is asking Elizabeth Dole about what she's going to be doing as First Lady. And she starts going on about being a supportive spouse. And Bob Dole makes a joke about calling her up for a transfusion. And then he looks at the monitor again. And meanwhile, Elizabeth Dole is going on about going around the country to places where mentally challenged youths are making beautiful products. And I swear to god, if she got any more condescending, I was going to seriously put my foot through the television.
所以拉里·金在问伊丽莎白·多尔作为第一夫人她要做什么。她开始滔滔不绝地谈论做一个支持性的配偶。鲍勃·多尔开了一个关于叫她来输血的玩笑。然后他再次看监视器。与此同时，伊丽莎白·多尔在谈论到全国各地精神残疾青年制作美丽产品的地方去。我对天发誓，如果她再表现得高高在上，我会真的把我的脚踢穿电视。
So then Bob Dole goes on the record as not speaking about Clinton's character by listing Whitewater and Filegate as two things he hasn't talked about, even though he just did. And then Larry King brings up more records. And then Bob Dole goes, "Trust."
所以鲍勃·多尔被记录在案，不谈论克林顿的性格，通过列出怀特沃特和文件门作为两件他没谈论的事情，尽管他刚才谈论了。然后拉里·金提到了更多记录。然后鲍勃·多尔说，“信任。”
And then Elizabeth Dole starts going on about how Bob Dole was a poor farmboy whose family moved their kids into the basement to rent out the house to make ends meet. How depressing is that? No wonder Bob Dole has a sour demeanor all the time, since he grew up with no windows.
然后伊丽莎白·多尔开始滔滔不绝地谈论鲍勃·多尔是一个贫穷的农场男孩，他的家人把他们的孩子搬进地下室，把房子租出去以收支平衡。那有多压抑？难怪鲍勃·多尔一直表情酸涩，因为他在没有窗户的地方长大。
And then Elizabeth Dole goes on some more, like maybe she should let her husband talk just a little bit. And then Larry King brings up the Jimmy Carter question. "Can you say you would never tell a lie?" And Bob Dole goes, "Yes." And Elizabeth Dole goes, "Yes." Whose question is that?
然后伊丽莎白·多尔又说了些话，就像也许她应该让她的丈夫多说一点。然后拉里·金提出了吉米·卡特的那个问题。“你能说你永远不会撒谎吗？”鲍勃·多尔说，“能。”伊丽莎白·多尔说，“能。”那是谁的问题？
And then they go on and on about affirmative action. And then Larry King promises to take phone calls for, like, the 50th time. Maybe no one is calling in or something. And then we get that health insurance commercial again and an ad for some ginseng-based energizing dietary supplement to help you feel not so old.
然后他们滔滔不绝地谈论平权法案。然后拉里·金承诺接听电话，比如，第50次。也许没人打进来或什么的。然后我们再次收到那个健康保险广告和一个关于某种人参基能量膳食补充剂的广告，帮你感觉不那么老。
Next, they're talking about the stock market. And we finally go to calls, but Larry doesn't seem to know how to work the phones. And the caller's from Georgia. And I was hoping it was that guy who called up when Jesse Helms was on, thanking him for all his work in controlling blacks, only he didn't say blacks. But it was only some guy asking about running mates again. The one call that they take on the show, and it is some yokel who didn't get that they weren't going to talk about possible running mates.
接下来，他们在谈论股市。我们终于转到了电话，但拉里似乎不知道怎么操作电话。打来电话的人来自乔治亚州。我曾希望是杰西·赫尔姆斯上节目时打来的那个家伙，感谢他为控制黑人所做的一切工作，只是他没说黑人。但那只是个问副手问题的家伙。他们在节目上接到的唯一一个电话，而且是一个不知道他们不会谈论可能的副手问题的乡巴佬。
So finally, we get Susan Molinari on the phone from a restaurant somewhere, gushing on and on about Bob Dole to the point where they probably should have cut her off. And Larry King asks whether Susan Molinari thinks her pro-choice abortion stand is going to be a problem. And Susan Molinari is going on about how, "This is the man to bring the convention together, and there is no greater honor in the world than to speak on behalf of the gentleman currently on your show." You would think Susan Molinari just found God or something, the way she was going on about it.
所以终于，我们让苏珊·莫利纳里从某处的餐厅打来电话，对鲍勃·多尔滔滔不绝，以至于他们可能应该切断她。拉里·金问苏珊·莫利纳里是否认为她支持堕胎的立场会是个问题。苏珊·莫利纳里滔滔不绝地说，“这是把大会团结在一起的人，世界上没有比代表你节目上的这位绅士发言更大的荣誉。”你会认为苏珊·莫利纳里刚刚发现了上帝或什么的，她谈论它的方式。
And all I want to know is does Susan Molinari on the phone to Larry King count as a paid Republican advertisement for Bob Dole, especially when Larry King points out that Bob Dole is the guest who's appeared most on the Larry King show? And then Larry King makes a point of reminding all the news flunkies out there that the two points from his show to remember are "Never lie" and "Susan Molinari." And I don't think November could be any scarier in my mind at this point.
我只想知道苏珊·莫利纳里给拉里·金打电话算不算为鲍勃·多尔支付的共和党广告，特别是在拉里·金指出鲍勃·多尔是拉里·金秀上出现最多次的嘉宾时？然后拉里·金特地提醒所有在那里的新闻失败者，从他的节目中记住的两个点是“永远不要撒谎”和“苏珊·莫利纳里”。在我看来，十一月不可能更可怕了。
Well, it is This American Life, the public radio show that is down with the king.
嗯，这是《美国生活》，那个与国王同在的公共广播节目。
Well, our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
嗯，我们的节目今天由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和多洛丽丝·威尔伯，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
You can read Danny Drennan's writing about 90210 and other things on the web, and we recommend this, http://www.inquisitor com. There's another dot in there. You can figure out where it is. If you would like a copy of this program, it only costs $10. Call us at WBEZ, 312-832-3380. Or email us, [email protected] And have you emailed us? No, you have not.
你可以在网上阅读丹尼·德雷南关于90210和其他事情的写作，我们推荐这个，http://www.inquisitor com。那里还有一个点。你可以算出它在哪里。如果你想要一份这个节目的拷贝，它只收10美元。打电话给我们WBEZ，312-832-3380。或者给我们发电子邮件，[email protected]。你给我们发过邮件吗？不，你没有。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
I think at this point, it's better to be the underdog. And we believe we're on target.
我认为在这一点上，最好是处于弱者地位。我们相信我们正处于目标之上。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。